why is this a
thing my lips on fire I'm actually okay
shut up
JC hey what's going on everybody for
first we Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and to
open up Season 22 we have a record 60
Wings on the table for in sync they've
sold more than 70 million records toward
the world and endures one of the finding
pop groups of a generation they're also
reunited not only on set today but with
a new single Justin Lance Chris JC Joey
welcome to the
show so Jus
whatever you start off so nice just
kidding go ahead Joey you guys are both
background Justin no milk no water Club
is there any wisdom any advice that
you'd like to pass on to the rest of the
guys before we get started no what you
said no milk no water no water I'll try
to do that I did I did no milk no water
I can't make any promises you know every
day is
[Music]
different okay
okay this is good I can eat this one
that's nothing wait that's the start
you're going to you're going to eat
those words bro oh my God this one's
good
[Music]
yeah so to start I'm curious what's the
most marked difference in how you
approach making a song together in 2023
versus 25 years ago like is the approach
closer to how do we make a classic
vintage In Sync song or is it more like
what would insync sound like if they
time traveled to 20123 yeah I think the
trick was to try to capture both you
know to for our fans that that have been
with us for so long you know to give
them something that felt not necessarily
nostalgic but familiar and then you know
see if we could you know take that sound
and and make it feel modern well we
listen to the world today we're we're
obviously influenced by 20 years of
experiences but we still want to give
them
us wait can we talk about that first
question for a lot longer that now
that's a good
tactic oh I like that I'm okay with that
that's good I feel like it's less hot no
it is garlic helps I that's how they get
you how would you break down the vocal
ranges and Sonic mechanics that go into
making a great boy band I think the
crazy part about it is that you have a
lot of these bands that were put
together and even the you know really
good bands One Direction not that that's
a bad thing yeah One Direction is an
amazing band but you have five guys that
are amazing singers and great soloists
so when they come out and do songs it's
like they you fight over where is this
going to be we kind of knew we sucked at
singing certain things so it was like we
just fell into our spots we fell into
our spots and we knew our place you know
it was like I knew I'd be the high stuff
these guys would do the leads Joy be in
the middle and Lance would be on the
base so it was a lot easier since we
started with a sound rather than five
amazing vocalists I mean not to say
we're not but I just
did
I'm good with it I can handle that I'll
take another bite go for
it nice I'm thinking I should take
smaller
bites you're
doing keep
going lean into it so the end sync
stadium tour shows that one's hitting
right now there we go it happens releas
come a little late right now good but
we're good sorry so the N Sync stadium
tour shows were such a production from
that fly rail entrance pyrot Technics
Justin's beatbox battle
interlude slightly
regrettable those are great Dr Dr we can
file that under you know slightly
regrettable bring it back when you think
back to the live on stage technical
difficulties or malfunctions is there a
story that stands out oh
tons getting caught in the trapo
platform came up or something honestly
that was the scariest that was a toaster
yeah we uh obviously pop up in the air
like Michael toter what's a toaster
toaster is like a it's basically it's a
pop-up you literally pop up like when
you're watching the stage all of a
sudden you see the artist jump all the
way up they don't jump that high we get
assistance basically catapulted by it
was back in the day though was it was
actually a weighted manual thing when
they had to release a lever so they had
guys underneath there somebody was
getting fixed with something I think
somebody broke their finger on one the
guy that was on mine walked over there
and I'm standing up and JC pops up me
I'm supposed to pop up and I'm standing
there going I just I'll just get up so
as I press rest I pushed down that that
box and released the lever as my legs
thank goodness nothing was underneath my
legs came up the whole thing came up and
slam my leg in between thank God my leg
is like a tree trunk cuz uh I didn't
break it but man yeah it it did a good
number on me it hurt it wasn't
[Applause]
[Music]
fun what's this one Los
Cante M we're getting somewhere I
immediately as soon as it touched my
lips different flavor profile oh yeah
it's like a
sweet uhhuh yeah that one that one hits
different now if you swallow it quick
does that help nope okay wait until you
breathe after like yeah yeah about 30 40
seconds that's this guy y the barboa
here I like it's pretty good actually
good go it's good what if anything do
you remember about the first time you
heard an insync song on the radio were
you all together we were all together in
Germany now we were at a radio station
in Germany it's the first guess first
couple of weeks we were over there and I
remember we were in Two Vans we were
like split up and there were so many
stuffed animals in the van because over
they love throwing stuffies yeah right
and it came on the radio and we just
kind of geeked out and we put on a
puppet show watching each other the C
were here on the radio obviously it was
cute all right so this is I'm going to
be a lot of fun two wings from now is
the halfway point Diablo power jab here
at 5 this is only halfway look like a
lot on that we're only halfway God I
thought we were like almost done I was
going to be impressed
myself you ain't a man unless you get in
there oh yeah oh this is going to be fun
just H that one's going to come a little
later mhm yeah that burns oh it's going
to be
[Music]
F oo that one
hits that one hits so we often like to
fact check the Larger than Life lore
that surround Our Guest so what I'm
going to do here is just hit you with
some things and you tell me if it's true
if it's fact if it's fiction and we'll
start though cut from the final edit is
true that insync was cast as Jedi
Warriors and Star Wars attack now we're
getting to the nitty-gritty question
true we were the three a few of us yeah
never made it I think I remember I think
I remember us getting a call like you
never going to believe what happened
yeah we were we were we were uh
Stormtroopers Jed Jedi Jedi we had to
like learn a bit of Sword choreography
yeah heck yeah me and Lance were so butt
hurt yeah but they got cut out anyway
when you guys got cut out we were
like the dumbest thing though is as we
were doing this the seeds you're
literally going vom Voom like an idiot
wish they I wish they had video I wish
they had the video of us somewhere I'm
well I'm sure they do cuz they filmed it
I have asked let's cut to it right now
asked I asked the producer Rick mallum
where's the footage cuz I know he has it
so let's get that footage please I want
to see it well didn't the Star Wars fans
go crazy that's while they edited it out
yeah yeah they did not like that idea
Lance yo true or false went
through I can finally say get out Round
of Applause everybody waited 23 years to
be able to say
that give him a round of applause so let
me mop my face off what was that but in
addition did you know that trained as a
cosmina certified by NASA and we once in
a position to be the youngest person in
human history to travel to outer space
that is true
yes thanks for reminding
me lanston gets to be a Jedi and get cut
out he got to go all the way to Russia
get to be real be a Cosa and got here
guys is your
commander um yeah no it was uh a very
intense situation um first I thought it
was a joke that they wanted me to do it
but um then I realized quickly that it
wasn't so I went over there trained for
half a year became a cosmina and then a
week before my launch everything gets
cancelled over Insurance cuz you know
should have went with Geo Hollywood
should have gone with a
Geico how about this fact or fiction the
hook on it's going to be me has that may
punctuation because Justin got a note
from a producer that was yeah I need you
to say it more like may like a meaner me
uh I don't remember if the specifics
were a meanor me but I was I saying it's
going to be me and he was like no no no
no no no and he was like it's may may
you also remember their Swedish accents
and they were and they had done a demo
of it and they were like it's like this
that was very like semi Lost in
Translation yeah well you know what's
funny specifically to Max Martin the
parts of their English that were broken
actually made them catchier songwriters
because they would put words away that
almost didn't make sense but when you
sang them they were more memorable right
and yes it was a specific note that I
got and I was just like this guy is
crazy and just going to be so mem worthy
yeah I knew one day they're going to
invent this thing called memes but yes
it was specific note and I I did it the
way that he requested and that's what
made the
[Music]
record anything with ghost in it you're
[__] uh-oh oh yeah there it comes oh
yeah there it goes wrong order
stop I don't give
[__]
so I'd say the Instinct Mania of the
early 2000s Rivals any sort of
fandemonium that you'd see today when
you think about the impressive or
horrifying lights yes just wait a
second what a
Miss proceed okay when you think about
the impressive or horrifying lengths
fans have gone to get your attention is
there a story that stands out there was
one experience where there were uh girls
that had gotten somehow I guess through
housekeeping in the hotel had gotten
into my
room and we're hiding in the closet and
I remember coming in the room and like
you just heard like surprise well you
heard like you heard
like you know you I was like H I was
like there's ghosts in this
S I also I remember one more thing we
were on the tour bus and we were leaving
this Open Air Festival there was a
stampede of fans that was running after
the tour bus and we were and they were
running in the field next to the this
road where we were and there was a
massive like hole in the middle of this
field and so you can imagine almost I it
it sounds not funny it's not funny
though very sad and we didn't
laugh no but they are okay so they were
F yeah they were fine but it was like a
video game where where you just see the
kids running and they're like
by large groups and and Lem um all going
off the cliff I feel terrible for those
for those for those females most of them
survive so it is funny yeah you know it
makes a great talk show anecdote in
retrospect you guys ready to move on
here to Sauce number seven what is this
hold on we we've got
there you go got sauce going down my
throat oh
well we we'll wait for you
Lance Ginger goat I'm sweating I think
we're officially
High it happens I catch it around this
time every time too that's the one thing
I remember about the first time the
serious like I remember looking at you I
was like there do I look at the one in
the middle there's three of
I do feel I'm getting to that I do feel
a lot better that you're eating them
with us though that well it has to go
that way can you imagine if I was just
sitting here just barking questions you
all right next Wing Chris next Wing now
I dug a little hole I want you guys to
run into it's going to be hilarious
you're the you're the new official six
member oh my yeah have Jack but we're
not going to split anything with him
point we learned our
lesson shame me
once okay do you have a most treasured
memory from the set of TRL like it's
kind of hard to put in context what a
cultural force that afternoon show was
well it was the last time that I think
the Young Generation flocked to a
certain area right after school like
everyone watch show now it's all spread
out and everyone's kind of segmented but
that was the last time everyone had to
show up and it wasn't just us and the
back street boys and 98 it was Limp
Biscuit it was Eminem it was all these
people all watching t RL you know kind
of like a big Melting Pot of people
watching the same show going well in it
was the it was the Pinnacle of pop
culture for at least a decade right at
that time if you had the number one
video on TRL it was bigger than having
number one song in the
country remember what I was saying about
us shuffling the deck Justin but one
sauce does always hold its place correct
that is the next one the bomb Beyond
insanity it looks like it's like lava
this this is the one that sent me into
like a
j Che cheers we dip it see you in yours
oh God okay here we go see you in the
bathroom all right oh I can smell it
already cuz that's that's a Reaper isn't
it in there oh Jesus yeah that that goes
immediate okay holy Moses make this
question really
quick wow well you know it's kind of
funny you say that cuz it's got a little
bit of a wind up and a multimedia angle
here all right so what we thought would
be fun is to do you know a style
retrospective here on D bomb so what
we've done is we've pulled some iconic
red carpet looks and we're just curious
how you reflect when you see those this
time around and we'll start where are
they with the 26th and [__] 26
annual American Music Awards I can't see
it which must have been an important
Moment Justin cuz I saw you revived it
for a Halloween costume just a few years
ago we did it shrunk we were actually
excited cuz we got to design these
wonderful why are you talking
normal why I can understand what you're
saying I understand we were very excited
that we got to design clothes and this
is what we came up with such a beautiful
thing of crying all about
it I like it I think it ages well I love
it the best moment for this was Joan
Rivers gave us most waterproof a
W you want that lubricated just spin on
it look at it up next shine it up
Grammy's 2001 wait wait wait I'm not mad
at the neither am I neither am I I'm not
mad at the outfit I'm mad at the hair
can we can we just can we just say
what's happening right now what holy
[__] why why is it so on the tongue like
it's like tongue it's like my M to my
throat and the other ones kind of have
like a cycle or a halflife you know like
as bad as they are the worse they're
going to get and then I feel like you
not be so normal this one's just like
mouth give me a little bit this just
dies no I gu I what you're going through
I'm going through too it's uncomfortable
you're just really good take a small lot
of
practice this is not how look what I
look at mom look what I did that was
[__] dumb all right up next that's
cool I don't care what you say that's
still cool I think I have that in a
story I'm delirious right now but I
think that's cool are you okay
I you know what I'm I'm weightless right
now I always get uh super liead this and
right now I feel very light whatever
Magic Carpet you're on right now that's
what I'm talking about that's right it
all right a whole new A Whole New World
A Whole New World yeah yep how are we
feeling fantastic why is this a
thing my lips are on fire I'm actually
okay shut up
JC
[Applause]
Cheers Cheers all right
okay was I remember that what's the uh
like that swearing quote on your show
like Let It Fly who's been the worst oh
who cusses the most Gordon ramsy by far
we actually full Martin sces did Count I
think it was what the [__] like 180 or
something in the episode alone wow yeah
so we'll be tough to break that we'll be
tough to break that Wolf of Wall Street
f f
f I think we did it broke another record
yes put us down goodness put us down
baby man when we had Shaq on the show he
said that not signing you guys when he
had the chance was one of his life's
biggest regrets missed it is it I mean I
don't I don't disagree with
him is it true that he let you record in
his home studio after hearing you guys
at an Orlando Magic game doing the
national anth well for the for the for
the cost of the engineer oh right do you
ever see his Jo his toilet seat they're
ginormous everything they are I'll never
forget like shaking his hand he was like
hey what's up how you doing I'm big sha
diesel your fingers his hand came all
the way up my forearm and I was
like and then even like on our show he
grabbed an entire gallon of milk but I
remember because of like the scale you
know like a regular cup of yeah he was
the niest the nicest to us then and he's
still the nicest human on earth
burning I feel my face all
right go for it open it this is
definitely the weekend right now no no
last dab we do yeah we are last dab bro
put my man do in the math fig this is a
fun part
[Music]
all right stab me up
dog I can't even say
rhubarb there you go there man I'm
getting in there jez I have to add a
little extra just to
yeah Glory that's what I'm saying no
risk it no biscuit yeah do it for the
Gipper give one what is it what is that
okay I'll wait till you guys have dabbed
it up oh my God Chris jeez dab it up
come on I'm not Lefty come on [__] you
do right easy hey you are you you're to
10 I need you to six come on friend
there we go there we
go let's go least your
seat
cheal and I'm
Italian you're not going to ask us
anything after this now right we leave
holy [__] uh maybe crap how do I that's
good sauce though that tastes good yep
at first yeah I'm waiting for
it okay the messiest one yeah oh yeah
it's it's coming
yeah y yeah yeah yep yeah that's a slow
burner yeah that's good so you told lies
that's cool that's cool told lies cool
that was the second worst I'm just happy
I did it without a drink I'm very proud
of myself I've seen you like this
the the years you know what I mean are
you all right I can I'm going to make it
I'm going to make I'm not all right
together you know we're in the same way
you know what we all wear all and
S [__] hot yeah cuz that was 98
Degrees all going in One
Direction you know Justin I remember to
close out our interview I was almost
nervous to ask you about ranking your
albums but I appreciate the honesty
right so in that spirit with our brains
on fire and mouth Ablaze I'm curious if
we can collectively come up with the
official Mount Rushmore of insync songs
Oh while our brains slow roast in hot
sauce I don't even know what the [__]
you said but just lean in just lean
in four or five four okay um Taran up my
heart's up there I would say tar my
heart bye byebye has to be up there bye
byebye would be up there then you got
it's going to be me it's going to be me
up there and then like a ball I mean I
thought she knew like the B promise she
going yes I promise she I thought she
knew has to be up there I thought she
knew you know what I put that number one
that's personal personal favorite I
thought she knew so I thought she knew
byebye bye Tearing Up My Heart it's
going to be me yeah how bye bye bye
let's go Joey it's going to be
disgusting with a with a promise you
with this I promise you like sliding in
honorable yeah an honorable mention and
if I could add drive myself crazy to
that we'll chisel one more Stone and
look at you guys taking on the wings of
death living to tell the tale now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you this camera this
camera this camera or this camera or
this camera there's a lot of cameras
today let the people know what you have
going on in your life right now my ass
is going to be on fire I can't wait
you're going to see me locally at Chuck
E cheeses bar mitzvas yeah after this
heading back to LA I'll be in the
bathroom for 2 days and uh yeah but
we're all going to be in a better
place
very
I don't even want to I don't even want
to go after that that's it Jo so messed
up he doesn't even know what he did what
did I say nothing that's that's it
that's it I'm out of here man okay can't
that was wonderful seriously my fingers
are why am I tingling good job guys
thank you it's lava snot oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[__] got
it
why did I do that
again hey what's going on hot ones fans
this is Sean Evans and if you would like
to get your hands on the Season 22 hot
Ones hot sauce lineup at this point you
know the drill heatness.com heatness.com
that's heatness.com to get your hands on
the hot ones Season 22 hot sauce lineup
ice cream not included be careful around
the eyes don't say I didn't warn you